tu es tanis tension luc ferrandez là
c'est parti pour elle tout à fait ça va
tout est une bataille toute une bataille
et prenons les trois thèmes qu'on
attende environnement
sécurité et mobilité et scanner plus
important que de l'autre où tout ça va
se mélanger à dissensions au cours de la
campagne mais je pense que plus que
celui aussi l'itinérance lui aussi
l'éducation dans de parler la sécurité
les finances il ya beaucoup de dossiers
je pense qu'une administration est
capable gérer tout seul en même temps on
peut on peut pas juste aller sur un côté
mais au niveau de la sécurité
actuellement je pense que c'est le
numéro en priorité pour les deux
candidats les candidats à la mairie quel
que soit le avec les autres partis aussi
et comment vous placez les avantages et
les inconvénients de chaque candidat sur
ses tableaux la nuit comment qui part à
gagnant ou en tout cas plus loin sur le
thème la sécurité par exemple je vous
dirais la sécurité qui parlent plus loin
ça doit te valérie planté son équipe à
cause du des financements qu'ils ont
parlé même si aujourd'hui n'en parle
plus durant les quatre dernières années
ça n'a pas été la priorité local avec la
police ce resort sont le sait de toute
façon au niveau de l'équipe codage un
peu biaisé parce que j'étais responsable
la police dans mon mandat mais
évidemment l'équipe coderre une
sensibilité peut-être plus grande pour
la sécurité quant à jean châtel blouët
luc
commentaires généraux s'ils voulaient
d'abord c'est quand même le début de la
campagne et sur les thèmes qui se
démarquent selon vous bon ça va être une
campagne difficile parce que d'abord il
ya un déficit qui est avec des sites qui
a été annoncée de 270 millions sur trois
ans près de 700 millions alors les côtes
ne peuvent pas faire des grandes
promesses la deuxième chose c'est que
monsieur cadart peut pas beaucoup accusé
son ancien champ favori qu'est par
exemple la grande des commerçants ou la
mauvaise situation économique de
montréal - sentir vraiment mieux que
d'autres villes onu après la pandémie on
ressent plus rapidement de la pandémie
alors il va ça va être du tirage de
cheveux moi j'ai un meilleur leader je
veux capable de faire des choses et puis
la réplique de valérie plante ça veut
dire vous vivez le passé puisque vous
intéressez critiquer mais n'a pas
vraiment le choix que de critiquer s'il
veut créer un momentum il faut qu'il
démontre que la mairesse elle est
incapable de faire son rôle parce que
sinon lui ai pas beaucoup de
propositions personnelles oui mais
idéologiquement c'est quand même d'un
groupe très différents l'un plat
absolument on l'a vu avec le rêve on va
parler tout à l'heure mais sur le
logement le logement je pense que c'est
là qu'on le voit le plus une crise du
logement à montréal une énorme crise du
logement le nombre de personnes ayant
quitté la ville a augmenté de 50 pour ça
les loyers ne sont pas abordables le
logement social avance pas assez vite là
le du côté projet montréal s'est on doit
construire rapidement beaucoup de
logement social héros doit imposer des
règles au promoteur denis coderre ne
nous tape pas révéler son plein mais
critiquent le plan de valérie plantes en
disant non et poser des règles au
promoteur dont on doit pas faire ça on
doit laisser le développement économique
faire son travail mais on comprend mal
son plein on aimerait mieux le contrôle
là dessus je rajouterais peut-être
quelque chose là on a beau parler du
logement puis qui est une manière là
dedans faut juste rappeler que c'est la
première fois qu'on a eu un camping que
durée extrêmement longtemps pour la
cause des itinérants et ceux qui ont
peur de trop grave et aussi son
notre-dame et la réaction de madame
plante a été très lente il a fallu que
le service de sécurité incendie lui dise
c'est dangereux il ya un feu on est
obligés d'évacuer
faute de quoi le camping serai toujours
là encore donc là-dessus madame plantes
de la difficulté à trancher dans ses
décisions est ce c'est clair et donne
denis coderre a aussi la fâcheuse façon
de décider trop rapidement sans regarder
tout ce qui va autour donc on est dans
les deux côtés l'eau avec deux chefs qui
d'un côté décide vite l'autre décide
moins vite la mobilité des gros thème la
dernière fois la mobilité est ce que
madame plante un avantage ou si monsieur
coderre selon vous qu un avantage là les
deux on est énorme inconvénient
désavantage parce que les travaux les
travaux le que ça soit souple madame que
madame plantes ou monsieur coderre ils
vont être à peu près au même rythme à
peu près au même rythme or ce sont les
travaux se sont en travaux qui pénalise
le plus il ya les travaux de la ville
centre et puis les travaux du
gouvernement du québec quatre heures
dans le tunnel lafontaine ça veut dire
quoi ça va énormément de voitures qui
vont vouloir passer par jacques cartier
ça veut dire qu'ils vont arriver dans le
ressort de lorimier sur sherbrooke ou
sur maisonneuve donc dans les deux cols
essayé de nous faire croire que ça va
mieux aller dans les quatre prochaines
années les salaires n'ont pas mieux tout
à fait mais là dessus je te rejoins luc
des deux côtés il faut dire peut-être
que bon hein valérie plantes à avancer
davantage avec les vs donc les voies
sécuritaire dans certains quartiers
projet qu'elle avait été initiée par
l'ancienne administration khadr donc il
ya quand même les deux vont se batailler
pour deux mondes est ce mon idée ça ça a
quand même fait du bien dans certains
quartiers quand les projets on y ont été
faits avec les citoyens sa peau était
facile mais l'idée est bien fait son
chemin et ça c'est un des vos projets
pour le rêve on va en parler mais pour
cette partie là je pense que c'est un
bon succès parce que les gens se sont
approprié les rues à cause de la
pandémie entre pardon gens du rêve le
regioexpress vélo sur bellechasse on
veut écouter monsieur coderre madame
plat celui sur saint denis on n'y touche
pas si monsieur colère mais ce livre de
chasse on veut toucher les côtes puis on
vit et on est capable de vivre ensemble
on n'est pas anti vélo on est pro
mobilité pour les pros fluidité jonah
kia n'a pas beaucoup en passant par le
fait qu' on est capable d'avoir la
moitié ça va être hamas
denis coderre lui a pas de problème à
détruire des aménagements sécuritaires
sont dits vie pour remettre des places
de stationnement et changer d'idée
dépendamment de la journée
bon voilà l'exemple concret
d'affrontements monsieur coderre annoncé
qu'ils allaient diminuer le rêve le qui
avait on va voir la carte novembre à
enlever grosso modo la moitié bon luc
ferrandez vous même qui avez été et
dépeint
caricaturé comme le maniaque des vélos
est ce que monsieur coderre ans se place
à un petit peu a mis des autos aussi
c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose
d'intéressant politiquement pour la
joute moi c'est sûr qu'ils envoyaient un
message ou à tout montréal c'est pas un
message pour bellechasse parce que
bellechasse le ya 800 places de
stationnement qui ont été retirés bien
2600 utilisateurs de vélo par jour et
dans l'est et c'est une rue sur laquelle
s'est souvent des côtés de maisons assez
souvent les la maison fait pas face à la
rue dans bien des cas c'est le côté de
la maison et les stationnements sont
devant donc sur les avenues alors ces
pauvres est que au niveau de cette
piste-là il va y avoir beaucoup de
satisfaction sur la déclaration de
monsieur cada il disait avoir beaucoup
de satisfactions à la à l'échelle de la
ville alsa est ce que le plan vélo c'est
pas trop agressif sous projet montréal
ça c'est vrai par ailleurs moi ce que
j'ai vu depuis hier c'est que beaucoup
de gens chez projet montréal ou ayant
voté pour projet montréal qui avaient
des réticences avec une partie du mandat
de valérie plantes qui avait l'épaule
intention d'aller voter et là ça va
déchaîner le vrai rebond est intéressant
à nice tension parce que a contrario ce
qu'il fait coderre il pas envoyer le
message que c'est un retour en arrière
pour le vote un peu plus progressistes
là donc je calcule difficile comment
vous voyez ça mais faut faut comprendre
comment ce projet là c'est fait à ces
faits durant l'été les citoyens au poète
informé n'ont jamais su qu'on a enlevé
les places de stationnement les élèves
sur toutes les rues c'est un projet de
mobilité qui peut être intéressant quand
il est travaillé avec ses citoyens dans
ce projet le trou sans plainte à
l'ombudsman de la ville marianne dans
son dernier rapport de melgven 108 pages
dont 80 parle du rêve bellechasse avec
des recommandations disant que ça a été
à l'encontre la charte des droits et
responsabilités
montréalaise une des seules villes en
amérique du nord qui en a eu les
éléments de base n'ont pas été
respectées et là je pense que de revenir
derrière de s'asseoir avec les citoyens
pas juste des cyclistes les résidents
qui reste là les personnes qui ont perdu
leur stationnement d'handicaper les
livreurs qui ont pas le droit d'en faire
sur les rues je pense qu'on doit se
rasseoir de revoir les priorités de
laisser les rêves là peut-être modifié
mais de s'assurer que tout le monde et
tout le cas des nids vous y vont en
profiter car vous êtes un bon calcul que
fait là moi je pense que oui qu'est né à
nis je pense que c'est de révéler non
parce que je la regarde oui si un expert
est prévu des places de stationnement
c'est moins pour enlever le playstation
3 ouais c'est ça ça ne se fait jamais
d'un consensus un moment donné il faut
faire un calcul ça c'est fait craindre
aux citoyens c'est ce que le rapport le
rapport note lankais qui a été fait dans
les 300 cas qui ont été faites alan boss
man c'était clair que les citoyens ont
reçu une lettre sans leur dire qu'on
enlevait les places de stationnement
dont ils ont fait pendant les vacances
de construction et on a enlevé les stats
822 place on a démoli le rehaut complète
où les gens rentrent par là ça change
une vie non les méthodes et moyens pour
en témoigner pas une rue parce qu'on met
des pistes cyclables où il y avait du
stationnement n'empêche
on ne peut pas négocier la sécurité des
familles contre des places de
stationnement celle des handicapés et
celle des familles aussi qui veulent
marcher les handicapés sont sortis en
faveur de la piste mais n'ont pas
aujourd'hui mais rapport va lire le
rapport de l'ambient ce match qu'à trois
fois j'ai lu un jour on le voit dire que
là on voit là on voit la frontière entre
les deux grandes écoles de pensée qui
vont s'affronter à montréal est
intéressant un évêque merci beaucoup
merci à lui